now getting back to the Oscar for a
minute okay you're gonna win you know
that right I don't know that well here's
the way I look at it they say your main
competition is this Austin Butler he's
still running around like he's Elvis I
can understand what he's challenged with
when you really commit to a role because
I'm guilty of wearing cowboy hats long
after I stop playing Cowboys
you've done this yeah I know that yeah
you know you invest a certain amount
into it and you take it with you and
then it worked for you and you want to
hang on to it
yeah but I've only read about this but
when someone is being vetted as the
front runner for the Oscar do you do you
sit there and go no don't jinx me like
that I would like the Oscar you would
like it right you would like the Oscar I
I would go absolutely
um have you fantasized about what your
speech would be
um
if I've thought about it it's that I
want to make sure that I don't run out
of time and I've I've been at a lectern
to receive an award only once really and
that was for the Critics Choice Awards
like three weeks ago I was not expecting
to have hear my name called and um
everything that I had in mind and
written on a piece of paper in my pocket
went out of my head the moment that I
stood up there and um I had to um really
I guess in a good way forget about all
that intellectual stuff and just speak
from the heart because I walked off
stage and I asked Angela Bassett what
did I just say
she goes she says you said go to the
light
that's all that matters maybe we should
do today we should rehearse in case you
win oh come on you wouldn't please do
that with you yes are you gonna write
down your Oscar speech or are you going
to wing it as they say oh no I I think
you know
um fail to prepare and you know as a
saying goes I'm I'm going to be ready I
mean there are many people that I have
to thank for bringing me to the place
that I find myself now it's been a
circuitous path that I've followed ups
and downs and everything's been on the
ascendancy which is I think optimism
speaking but at the same time
I you're only as good as the people you
work with and
it I would be remiss to not acknowledge
who they are I would be remiss to not
acknowledge who you're keeping company
with